reaction to the completion of the Muller
report was Swift
the Justice Department notified top
congressional leaders from both parties
that it had received the report from
Special Counsel Robert Muller and many
including all eight Democrats in
Congress who are running for the
president called for the report to be
made public at O'Keefe is on Capitol
Hill with the very latest said good
morning good morning Michele when
Washington's most anticipated moment in
recent memory actually happened almost
nobody was up here on Capitol Hill
Congress is on recess but that didn't
stop members of both parties from
calling for the reports full release
that report needs to be made public the
Democratic race for president quickly
became a campaign to make the Muller
report public nobody including the
President of the United States is above
the law the American people have a right
to know competing candidates found
common ground in calling for the release
of the unredacted report we are owed the
facts and if we do not receive them 243
years in there's nothing that guarantees
us a 244 despite the news there will be
no new indictments Beto O'Rourke did not
back off his call to impeach the
president members of the House to bring
up but Democratic leaders in Congress
aren't yet ready to go there I'm not
going to draw any conclusions until we
see not only the whole report but the
underlying findings and documentation
Democrats said they're prepared to
subpoena the report and suggested the
special counsel should testify I think
it would be very valuable to the
American people to have mr. Muller come
before the Judiciary Committee in public
and walk the country through the report
while president Trump's 2016 campaign
manager Corey Lewandowski said Democrats
now owe the president an apology this
witch hunt is finally over
675 days one year ten months and six
days 40 million dollars of taxpayer
money wasted like Lewandowski other
Republicans called for the reports
release but argued Democrats need to
accept the results did not accept those
findings will be really traumatic for
the American people
important to point out the House voted
unanimously all Democrats and all
Republicans to call on the Justice
Department to release that mother report
in full they took that vote before their
recess
some Democrats cite a special counsel
investigation that was held in the early
1990s after that Branch Davidian
compound rate in Texas as a reason for
the full release of the Mulla report
because that Branch Davidian report had
been released we should know more within
hours about how much we might actually
learn from the Attorney General Anthony
had okay thanks Edie